[Applause]
[Music]
before we get started let's just pay the
bills right now walk to Main Street
boxing gym this is all the main street
fighters come from 100% as you can see
there's a lot of bags full size ring for
your lipstick training a lot of
Champions came in and out of this place
come here and train young and old every
bag imaginable
speed bag heavy bag full body bag full
size ring combat toes mr. king
the fight is upon us Anthony Joshua
where's this Alexander Povetkin and we
haven't seen torn limb pians two
heavyweight Olympians go at it in a long
time but these are two gold medalists
you understand so they will exercise the
three P's of boxing professionalism
poise and polish so and in doing so they
have been grown that's what a polish
comes in you understand they are shown
how to act how to execute the fights how
to be polished all right so everything
will come out correctly the punches that
the movement that you have is the right
hands the crosses the hooks two
uppercuts the clinching anything that
needs to be done it will be done with a
level of professionalism that you have
not seen and have you a division mental
all time because both men are on the big
gold medalist alright one won the gold
medal in Athens that was what 2004 and
the one one that was Alexander Povetkin
and the other one won the 2012 in London
gold medal and that was Anthony Joshua
now there's a huge age difference in
this fight
you have Anthony Joshua which is 28
years old then you have Alexander
Povetkin which is 39 years old Alexander
Povetkin is a curious case because he's
the guy you do not want to fight he has
one loss on his resume resume and that
is to Klitschko in his prime it's the
only loss and he lost his belt in a 12
round hard-fought decision no so you
find a prime Klitschko and go 12 rounds
with him that's saying a lot you know
and he gave as well as he took but he
just couldn't get around klitz close jab
and that right hand Emanuel Stewart I
believe was still alive in clinicals
corner that is the Hall of Fame trainer
so that means Klesko was well focused
and ready for that fight fighting that
hard-nosed fighter Alexander Povetkin is
known in the circles as the boogeyman
the babadook the dude you do not really
want to fight and unless you are forced
to so a lot of times when he gets fights
he's usually to mandatory so that goes a
long time for saying that he lost his
belt to Klesko and now he's trying to
regain that same belt by fighting
Anthony Anthony Joshua well who Anthony
Joshua let's go but before a faded old
ERK let's go that day that he knocked
out but gave him hell and getting
knocked out
knocked out Anthony Joshua so Anthony
Joshua
he's a very polished fighter
professional both men are professionals
but he is groomed in a manner that he is
trying to reach superstardom
all right he's already packing out
Wembley Stadium 90,000 and in various
stadiums I think this is his fourth
stadium that he's selling out so and he
also has four belts he has every belt
except for Deonte wildest belt which is
the WBC belt which is probably the most
prestigious out of all belts is the WBC
bill because the WBC belt is the green
belt as the lineage of prestige to it so
if that's being said Alexander Povetkin
is going up to fight Anthony Joshua for
his titles all his titles now this he is
a mandatory for one of Anthony Joshua's
belts and like I said no one wants to
fight Povetkin at all so he will be a
mandatory for anybody that needs to
fight him how do I see this fight going
well let's just say that I see this
fight going hard for fight well you have
to think about it this way Alexander
Povetkin fight before this he was the
mandatory to fight David Price David
Price is six-six lanky rangy fighter and
he was using that as I guess rangefinder
to figure out if he can actually beat
Joshua well Povetkin knocked out David
Price upset the applecart
all right now um Anthony Joshua for
Joseph Parker in his last fight he knows
it's
wrong decision Joseph Parker is the
relative same size as Povetkin but not
the same polish as a Povetkin you
understand its difference it's a huge
difference in the quality of fighter
Deontay Wilder in Anthony Joshua was
supposed to be doing this fight now
they couldn't come together on terms so
you have Anthony Joshua versus Povetkin
and you have Deontay Wilder versus Tyson
Fury both fighters can lose these fights
and potentially destroy a unification
about within the heavyweight division so
we can have one unified heavyweight
champion of the world why didn't they
get it together
I don't know politics egos hubris who
knows but we're not here to speculate
right we're here to give exactly
accurate predictions so you can go into
this fight which friends and let them
know you know a little something so you
know what you're looking for when you
see this fight I believe Anthony Joshua
is gonna come out fast he's going to be
establishing his jab he's gonna want to
establish his jab he wants to shoot his
right hand but then he has he's a
massive individual he has a lot of
muscles he gets tired quickly because
those muscles need oxygen blood flow
Povetkin has a fighter's body a box's
body lean not too much fat just enough
to absorb very lean very strong very
durable so he'll be there all night long
you best believe unless you get them out
which I don't see Anthony Joshua getting
Povetkin out of there I can see Povetkin
getting Joshua out of there but I can't
see
Anthony getting Povetkin out of there I
wanna see
comes with some serious stuff alright so
this fight here this fight is a hard one
cuz the babadook is in the building and
boy oh boy the boogey man is here to
play
I hope Anthony Joshua cuz he slimmed
down for this fight he lost significant
muscle mass to get into a position where
he can actually move with Povetkin so
hopefully he's in tip-top shape
I know training in Russia Alexander
Povetkin is a hundred-percent boxing
shape going into this fight my
prediction for this fight wow this is
huge
12 round unanimous the unanimous
decision fen Anthony Joshua but I can
also see a ninth round TKO for
perfection
if Rebecca gets this fight it's insane
because he destroys the chances of
Anthony Joshua or fighting Deontay
Wilder this is combat talk with the king
let's see if I was right
[Applause]
[Music]
you